one thing people got upset about me  because it hurts everybody's right to a  peaceful protest and I know during these  times we have that we can put something  in in place and I said peaceful protest  let's say a piece of protest from eight  in the morning to five in the afternoon  yeah we all have the night that means  the host loves it three problems so you  need to go home and you all get arrested  that's from Dan zenzel movie you either  want to go home or go to jail because  it's not peaceful anymore  by definition  it's not peaceful after 5 p.m I guess if  you have a day job sorry you can't  protest this is not free speech my  friends